foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar which is
on tools and Partnerships for
sustainable increases in rice production
I'm Dusty Vias and I'm a senior
scientist at LGC by search Technologies
and I'm going to be the moderator for
today's event
today's educational webinar is presented
by labroots and brought to you by LGC
bios search and if you want to know more
about us go and look at our bios search
tech.com website
and we would encourage you to
participate by submitting the questions
that you may have during the
presentation all you need to do is
simply type them in the ask a question
box which is on the right hand side and
then just press click we'll answer as
many questions as we as we have time for
at the end of the presentation
you may also ask a question
um in the box and if you are having any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentations let us know through there
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
today for today's webinar her name is Dr
Catherine Steele and she's a senior
lecturer in the sustainable Crop
Production at Bangor University
and for me she's very very important and
she's made a significant contribution to
Rice Market development globally
for a complete biography of our speaker
and myself please look at the biography
tab on the top of your screen
so Catherine please feel free to begin
your presentation
hello this presentation is about tools
and Partnerships for sustainably
increasing rice production so the tools
are a new database of off-the-shelf
markers that can be used for this and
the Partnerships that we developed were
between rice scientists biotechnologists
and bioinformaticians
so molecular markers have um evolved
over the last few decades the first
generation you may be familiar with were
mainly hybridization based or random PCR
markers a second generation
um were more sophisticated random
markers such as aflps and then
directed PCR markers targeting simple
sequence repeats now a lot of rice
breeders will be very familiar with
these microsatellites or SSRS because
they've been become they've become very
well applied in rice breeding mapping
and selection using marker assisted back
crossing that's been used for well over
20 years now by breeders
but
um more and more sequencing first by
Sangha sequencing and then
um the advance of Next Generation
sequencing has increased the number of
single nucleotide polymorphisms that we
call Snips
um that can be identified and these are
much more
um
widely
scattered among across the Genome of
rice and much more likely to be within
genes or very closely linked to genes
rather as compared to the
microsatellites SSRS
um so in since about
um 10 or 15 years ago the
um cost of Next Generation sequencing
has reduced and this is enabled a number
of Next Generation Market systems such
as um rad seek and GBS which are very
similar techniques and now um low
coverage whole genome sequencing
um but also just because so many more
genomes of different varieties have been
sequenced and become available there is
a huge amount of information now on
single nucleotide polymorphisms that
Rice breeders can tap into
foreign
so we built our project around rice
breeders so four different organizations
represented on this prod on this slide
who wanted to all improve their marker
assisted breeding using snips
and
this Consortium was set up through a
funding initiative from the UK
government known as innovate UK
and
um we work together with
biosearch Technologies
as well or LGC as I'll probably call
them in this talk
um to
um
develop better methods for
um the use by those breeders
so it was a partnership with the
Breeders AIMS in mind
um to make sure that what we were
developing would actually work and not
just be what a bioinformatician thought
we should use
so
we're targeting Asian Rice breeding so
mainly Indica rice but
um we were making sure that we were
incorporating
um
a greater diversity than just Indica in
our design of markers
so the partners the first in Nepal is
animal view private limited animal view
means a beautiful sorry it means
precious seed I should say
um and they are a small breeding company
they do not have their own breeding
station they grow all their test
varieties with Farmers on farm and this
works brilliantly
uh also in Nepal on the top right we
have narc and we were working with two
divisions of narc the national
agricultural research Council of Nepal
and they have
um breeding programs focused on cold
tolerance blast resistance and bacteria
Leaf blight which I will just call BLB
resistance
um the
third partner going around in the
clockwise manner is nibji in Pakistan
um and they are looking to improve
aromatic rights for salinity and drought
tolerance and also BLB resistance
and then on the um
the last section we've got SKU West from
Cashmere
and they are also interested in
improving aromatic rice and their focus
in this project was to look for
resistance markers to bikaner disease
which is becoming more prevalent in
rice-growing regions of Asia
so
producing sufficient rice for Asia
involves
um
not only targeting yield disease
resistance and grain traits but traits
for climate adaptation such as heat
stress drought tolerance salinity
tolerance so it's a huge number of
traits for breeders to be able to
Grapple with and
molecular breeding has tended to focus
on simple traits such as disease
resistance where we can identify single
genes associated with disease resistance
and use them
in micro assisted selection using SSRS
but when you're wanting to incorporate
multiple traits then a more
sophisticated technique for screening
and selection
and a wider number of markers is
required
um we also need to consider crosses with
locally adapted land races that are
bringing those new and novel traits that
may improve climate adaptation in rice
into higher yielding varieties or
varieties with specific quality traits
so using these more efficient tools and
approaches can hopefully improve the
efficiency of breeding rice and by
working with Partnerships and sharing
resources sharing best practice and
sharing experiences and being able to
help each other to solve problems going
forwards are really really important and
that's what we managed to do over the
five years or more that we've worked
together in this partnership
so the location of the um Partners is
shown in this map I just like to show
this to sort of show although we're
working in three different countries
Pakistan India and Nepal the area where
the rice is being produced is quite
similar
um this whole region depends on rice in
Nepal it accounts for um just over half
of Agriculture all agricultural
production 51.7 and there's a huge
amount of rice genetic diversity across
these regions where we're working
so in the poll the
um
the work was done in a number of regions
so the yellow part is the Teri
um where rice is grown in um flooded
fields and then in the green area you've
got the mid Hills where rice tends to be
grown in more Upland sloping conditions
and narc themselves are based in
Kathmandu so you can see the um arrow in
the middle there in the central region
of Nepal but not also have a
um
a research
Center for doing their screening down in
the terrai in hard enough
and then APL have
um three different sites on this map all
in the Teri but spread out across Nepal
and this gives good amount of
information for screening for disease
resistance across the whole region or
the whole of Nepal
so the project initially started off
doing next Generation sequencing of nine
different rice varieties now this
diagram on the right shows the 12
chromosomes of rice each
block is 12 chromosomes but each block
is broken down into nine separate
columns and the diversity of or the
density I should say of snips
is shown in the
um the the red color so where the red is
darker there is a greater diversity of
snips that are potentially useful for
developing into Casp technology
um
we use this whole genome sequencing to
compare
varieties these nine varieties that have
been selected by our partner breeders
and they were varieties that were all
being used as parents in their breeding
programs
um a lot of them were donor pairs of
parents of disease resistance and other
important traits
so
from that we found three hundred
thousand Snips and thirty nine thousand
Intel variants and
those were filtered through
bioinformatics to make sure that they
would work as cast designs
so that um
they could be assayed using that
technique
and those have been published in the
paper that's cited at the bottom here
and along with the coding which is
available to be downloaded as a
supplementary
um
um information that you could if you've
got your own right genomes you could
follow that to try and find
um Casp that may be specific to your
populations if you can't find them from
these off-the-shelf ones but hopefully
what I'm going to go through for the
rest of this talk will inspire you that
we have now got
um off-the-shelf markers that can pretty
much be used in any um rice breeding
program
so a little bit more detail about these
tools Casp is a technology that is
licensed to LGC by search Technologies
and it is a PCR based technique that is
almost as flexible as microsatellites it
can be used in small numbers to do
exactly the same jobs that you would use
microsatellites for in micro assisted
back Crossing and qtl mapping
um LGC have a second method
um seek snip which they developed during
this program
and we were very lucky at the end to be
able to include some sneak snip seek
snip in the research with two of the
partners and I'll come on to that but
seek snip is a high throughput
um screen of thousands of markers
now Casp and seek snip show concordance
between the Technologies and we have
demonstrated that by designing seek snip
um well I should get this right by
designing Casp
at a large scale and then using those
marker designs for Casp for seek snip we
can
allow the two to be um the same loci can
be tested with both meth techniques but
it only works because of the
bioinformatics that we used on the cast
designs
and
the beauty of this is that the the
services provided as a full service
including DNA extractions and the
um you don't actually need to run these
in your own lab if you don't want to you
can order cash to run in your own lab
from LGC but you can and we were
expecting our partners to want to do
that because they'd been doing that with
microsatellite but when they realized
how simple it was to just order the um
Casp
um through this full service with LGC
and just sends their Leaf samples and
you can see on the bottom right hand
picture there
um the team in Nepal sampling leaves to
send off in these boxes to LGC when they
realized how efficient that was they
haven't actually
bothered to run the Casp in their own
Labs but clearly can be run in your own
Labs if that suits your program
so we actually improved on the original
designs from the nine genotypes in the
second tranche of funding that we had
from the UK government
and that allowed us to incorporate
um
121 additional genomes
to take account of extra variation and
then we were able to improve the designs
of the the Casp assays so that they
looked at
um non-target Snips or indels in the
sequences of all of these additional
diverse genomes from indica and Japonica
and
um varieties from many different
countries
so that they should work in a much wider
set of
genomes
and from those we were able to
hone in on a 1.3 million improved assay
designs of which nearly 100 million were
predicted to be functional that means
they're in genes and have an effect on
the protein product that's produced from
the prediction of the sequences
and
um between them you could between any
two of those 129 genomes there were a
minimum of 23 000 pairwise polymorphisms
um that could be found so even very
closely related varieties you could find
um useful polymorphisms among them
so
from those we the project allowed us to
validate a set of 5 000 that we um
chose we selected from that 1.3 million
based on the advice of our breeding
partners
and the success rate of those becoming
usable wet lab validated Casp was
between 72 to 90 percent depending on
um
a number of factors
so out of those we have got
4867 the numbers going up all the time
whenever we um test a few more
um and so that
um on the right there you can see
um
3355 of those used on 178 genotypes of
which only 10 I think were used in the
original sequencing so the rest
um over 160 genotypes varieties that
hadn't been tested hadn't been used to
design these primers they were tested
blind as it were with these with these
markers these cats and markers and the
results there show that they can
discriminate the Japonica varieties
which are on the bottom left in purple
from the indicas which are on the right
in the light green color and all the
Basmati varieties are in the red color
and then there were intermediate
varieties you won't be able to read the
names of those but for example Pusa
Basmati won although it is a Basmati it
comes in that intermediate set because
it contains
um diversity from because it's a modern
variety and it's had introgressions from
some of those other groups
so modern varieties when they when
they've been had that complex pedigree
they tend to fall into that intermediate
category and so our cast set were very
good at distinguishing
um these different types of variety
um so the success rate
um was was I say 90 for Casp
we also
um validated uh well we tested 15 000 of
the designs in zeknit and the success
rate of those for design to wet lab
validated was 93 more on six snip in a
bit
um and all the the loci that we've
designed so all designs are going to be
available very soon from LGC by search
Technologies in a searchable database
and from that you will be able to look
for your genome position of Interest or
a gene that you the idea of a gene that
you are interested in and the regions
flanking it
um or even you can look at
microsatellite markers and snip markers
that have been used in chips by Erie
so you can go into that database and
look at those regions and that will tell
you which novel cast designs are in
those regions and then you should be
able to click on them and download
the information that you can then use to
order if you want to try them in your
own breeding program and again it it's
great if you send your Leaf samples and
then LGC can just send you a data a
spreadsheet of your genotypes at the end
and
well I think it's just going to be an
amazing set of new
off-the-shelf markers that should work
in well yeah you should you'll probably
get one in nine we'll give a result if
you choose a batch
um one in nine should give a result and
if they're polymorphic in your in your
material then you should be able to use
it and work with it
so the next few slides are going to go
into a bit more detail of what our
partners have achieved using these new
markers during this development process
and more recently
so
APL in Nepal are very
um
well in Nepal aromatic rice is very
important it increases it increases
um farm income by about 40 if they can
sell a fragrant aromatic rice and prior
to this project so Nola seganda had been
bred by APL as the first modern aromatic
rice variety it was released in 2014 and
it has pushed the Basmati one as one of
its parents
so you can see that on the top right in
the little photograph there that was
crossed with two local land races one of
those gradually meschino is shown on the
um photograph
and from the progeny we you well APL
used Casp
to
identify lines that carried the
um
Target traits for Aroma and for um
traits such as disease resistance and
um also selecting the local variety
parent recurrent parent for background
traits
that would bring that adaptation to the
local environment for Nepal
and
the one of the markers is targeted to
the the fragrance
um allele the badh 2.1 locus of um
basmati rice well it's in it's in
um a lot more
um fragrant rice than just Basmati but
there are also minor qtls for Aroma as
well so we've got in our set of markers
we've got
um casts that will Target those as well
and
so this breeding program really Advanced
using Casp um I think at least three
generations of marcosystem back Crossing
and selection was done by APL remember
they don't have a reading
um farm and they don't have they don't
have their own research station and they
don't have a lab so they were doing the
selection in Farmers fields and they
were sending the leaves off to
um LGC for genotyping
and we were working with them to help
interpret and um
smooth out the process for them and and
they've got really good at doing it now
and
in addition to that right at the end we
were able to run
um
fifteen thousand six-nip
and the aim of that was to actually look
at Pure Line selection
as I mentioned APL RC company they um
self-certified seed to Farmers in Nepal
and they need to make sure that seeds
are pure we were able to extra purify
um
synola saganda
through the
um the use the use of seek snip so the
next slide shows on the right you can
see
all of the snow the second
samples that they tested with seeksnip
and within that population out of the so
we we
um
we ordered 15 000 seek snip of which 13
115 I think were
um worked
and um and were polymorphic
and out of those
um in in just the sonola saganda
population there were
um
1207 that were polymorphic and you can
see in this
um principal component analysis that the
true type are the ones at the bottom
left and you could see three clusters
where there's some off types within that
population so we the breeders in APL
were able to discard the off types from
that and make sure that their certified
seed was really pure for sonola saganda
so that was just from the original run
of the seek snip but it wasn't just
um cenola saganda that was included in
that and the next slide will show those
but I'm just going to mention while I'm
on this slide that another organization
nibji in Pakistan were also able to
benefit from running seek snip and so
we're really pleased that both
organizations
um we're able to do this so within the
nibji budget we had enough funds for
2006 snip to be tested and they were
using it in a mapping population
uh between super Basmati and an eerie
donor variety
and these there were um 1291 that were
polymorphic within that cross and again
these were
the um the sneak the sneak snip designs
were from the full set and we hadn't
used super Basmati within that to design
the um you can't just use that these
parents actually to design or to
um sequence for the designs so it was a
good success rate of polymorphism in the
nib G set as well
so APL back to APL the entire breeding
program they had they made 11 crosses
during our
um project targeting as I say the
disease resistance and aroma
and they also did linkage mapping to
confirm that some of the
bacteria blight resistance genes
were associated with the cast markers so
previously they'd relied on
microsatellites and these cast markers
for this designed for the same targets
were equally good at co-locating in the
breeding program
um through the field trials where they
screened them for BLB bacteria lift like
resistance
so they multiplied those new BLB
resistant lines and
um those are in the pipeline for
resistance in addition the the aromatic
crosses from the two crosses mentioned
in the previous slide they've now got 10
Advanced aromatic lines in yield trials
in Nepal
and in addition from a cross between
hard enough one and and another
um donor variety they have developed
super early lines so these were selected
for early flowering
um and this means that um and and
they're also highly disease resistance
and this means that they can be grown
early in the tighty season
um they're very early sewn and um they
allow Farmers more flexibility and have
greater income through the season
so that's
um APL
not
nationalized research program the
um
all of the seed
um
certification and release is done
through the national race research
program nrrp and so they lead the
coordinated field trials
and nrrp collaborated to evaluate
evaluate the crosses from APL in the
um field trials as well
for blast BLB and Aroma and they're now
evaluating 33 Advanced entries under
multi-location trials
and this is ongoing and hopefully
varieties will be released over the next
few years
so going back to the seek snip
the
um fifteen thousand six-nip
um that were originally ordered
were tested on 108 genotypes
and these are shown in this PCA on this
slide
so Advanced breeding lines from APL are
in the red
sorry advanced modern varieties are in
the red Advanced breeding lines are in
the
um
uh green and light blue at the bottom
so the two best aromatic reading lines
are in the the light green and the light
blue and the synola saganza is in the
um darker blue slightly darker blue
so what we did for six snip evaluation
we
we found that
um 67
were highly informative and polymorphic
within this uh these 108 Gene attacks
remember these are quite um
thank you
non-genetically
non-genetically diverse they're quite
uniform because they're all from the um
breeding program of
um APL but you apart from the ones in
red
and they are
um
these markets are giving a huge amount
of discrimination between them and
really useful for selecting
um and also selecting against the off
types
so when the analysis that was done was
principal component analysis and what my
colleague John Wickham did who did this
analysis was to take the original 13
polymorphic Snips and run it in the
analysis and then he just took out the
ones that were polymorphic in sunola
seganda to run
um that analysis
um and then he was able to look at the
um
individual breeding lines and
run the the analysis again with the
smaller subset of markers each time
repeating the principal component
analysis and and then any markers that
gave exactly the same pattern of allele
calls between the same lines he would
just replace it with one of those to
reduce it to a smaller subset that could
still separate in principal component
analysis those varieties and that but
that led to 39 highly informative snips
which
um of those we then ordered or APL then
ordered
um Casp would be done on those using
um
the select using the lines from their
fields
and
um that showed that 67 of those six knit
were suitable for running as Casp and if
you remember that this is a non-diverse
set of lines the um
the ones that were monomorphic in this
could um if you added those ones in
you'd get an even higher success rate
but but because they were monomorphic in
this population they weren't usable but
they may have been usable in a wider
um diverse set
so we so yeah John Wickham basically
says um conversion of cast from six
using these designs is brilliant and
he's so thrilled with the way that the
APL have been able to
improve their seed Purity and improve
the purity of the new breeding lines as
well so they're taking these cats
forward for subsequent selection in
their marker assisted back cross
breeding program
there we go so moving on to narc the
second division of not which is
biotechnology
um so this has
um
this was run by um
by resham angai and he was focusing on
improving
um
high altitude rice
um and also looking for disease
resistance and agronomic traits
so there were two varieties come off
four and generally marshy which were
crossed with donor varieties and these
were some of the lines that were chosen
for the original sequencing
and from this 18 blast resistance
um
enhanced rice lines were selected
resham also did qtl analysis in the
population and confirmed the Casp for
the blast resistance Gene Pi 33 was
co-segregating with blast resistance and
this was in high yielding cold tolerance
breeding lines
and he also looked at a diverse set of
lines that he was interested in using as
parents in reading and has identified
traits Mark cast markers associated with
traits for
agronomic photosynthetic and biotic and
abiotic stress tolerance traits
so moving on now to nibji in Pakistan so
nibji have um
as I mentioned previously also been
looking to improve aromatic rice and
their main focus is to has been to
improve super Basmati for disease
resistance so bacteria blight resistance
um and they've got
the success in
um producing single Gene a single
genotype with three resistance genes
pyramid in it pyramid it into it at 90
homozygosity they've also
um confirmed that
um
uh I think they've got five cast markers
for xa5 it's like a haplotype and when
these are all present they've got
homozygosity within their lines so
they're very um confident with those xa5
markers but also
um they've been using the the others and
they're getting really good results so
they are expecting one of those disease
resistance
um Basmati types to be released by 2026.
and they're very confident about that
they've also
um selected numerous lines with
combinations of two x-ray genes for
bacteria blight and they've been
screening a training population for
um
genomic selection as well to look for
diverse
um to look at the diversity and try and
Associate those
um
important traits for breeding with
markers and then use that going forwards
in their reading program and finally
they've got another cross with super
Basmati and another
Eerie line which is a drought tolerant
line that they have identified qtls for
Drought tolerance and grain traits and
the graph on the
um that slide is showing some of their
qtls on chromosome 3 that they have
identified and that is being developed
by the team at nibji into a publication
which will be coming out hopefully
fairly soon
and then moving to India so School asked
I think is how you're supposed to
pronounce it
um they are a university in India
um they're also interested in aromatic
rice
but what they used
um what they did when they were um
able to test a large number of cats was
to screen a diverse collection of
accessions from India
from the Himalaya region of India and
they have looked at that and identified
um
they've run cluster analysis and
identified
um six casps that are largely
differentiating local land races from
the temperate exotic germplasm so those
cats are particularly useful for
maintaining local adaptation going
forwards and that's already been
published in genetic resources and crop
evolution
squashed also have a mapping population
have developed a mapping population for
bacardne disease and they've been
screening lines for resistance and you
can see some of their resistant and
susceptible lines clearly in this plug
tray experiment
and
success has come they've identified qtls
a number of qtls for bikaner resistance
and two particularly interesting ones uh
one on chromosome two shown in the
diagram here and one on chromosome six
using um qtl mapping based on the Casp
genotypes
um that they ordered through the
genotyping service of LGC
and that currently continuing to do that
with fine mapping using those markers
to home in on hopefully the candidate
Gene and again a paper is in
preparation and should be released
should be published soon
about the the carne resistance Gene
in in that population
resistance qtls I should say
so it's been an amazing few years
five or six years at least
we've done a huge amount and worked with
a huge number of rice breeders and
they're also pleased with what we've
achieved through the development of Casp
and then going on to the seek snip
um the
um
the project has been
um highly successful and we've
summarized here the some of the
achievements we have 1.3 million new
rice genome assays that have been
designed and are going to be made
publicly available off the shelf so any
breeder can order them and run them
themselves
we have
um acid
over 8 000 right successions in this
project across all the partners with
either Cass or seeksnip
and we've got at least
um
4867 casts that have been validated
across the entire project that number is
going up
um every few months when we run another
project we've just run a project through
Bangor with Pakistan researchers
targeting Casp in
um amylose genes that hadn't been run
and validated previously so that adds
another 10 or 12 I think to uh are set
we've um got Nepalese scientists who've
been trained in qtl analysis I went out
and did a training course during the
project so that they can use the data
more effectively when it comes through
we've got at least 26 different rice
collections or populations that have
been genotyped in the project so that's
for diversity genetic diversity screens
we've had 12 crosses that were made
specifically for this project we've Run
10 rounds of cast that again that
number's going up
um but on this project there were 10
Rounds
um that LGC has contributed to the
project
um eight early careers at least have had
their uh have early career researchers
have at least had their careers enhanced
through the project activities and
um so far there are three published
papers in international journals that's
the
um Indian Himalaya land races the
original cast designs
um and the
um
the location of markers associated with
disease resistance genes as well that is
published in agronomy
um there's going to be at least two more
papers coming out and then we are in the
process of publishing the um
the full cast design paper that will
accompany the database release as well
but then we haven't released any new
varieties yet from the project but as as
you will have seen going through there
are a number of new high yielding
varieties that will be
um and look that are in the pipeline and
pending their performance in the
um all area trials they should be
expected to be released in the coming
years in Nepal India and Pakistan so it
is a case of watching out for those and
yeah keeping in touch with the
developments
going forwards
so I would just like to finish with the
acknowledgments here for all the people
who and organizations who've been
involved with this work it's it's been a
really amazing team to work with and a
lot of people have put a lot into this
so we've got the team from Danga past
and present colleagues the skewast team
led by Arif Shakari the nibji team led
by Dr Mohammed Arif and the APL team
um
they're all great and
um narc led by resham and we had a
project partner in the Agri epicenter
that helped with the funding
um reports to the funders and then the
LG team and Dusty as well who is part of
this meeting who's been a real support
throughout the whole thing and answered
all sorts of questions about cast
designs and how to get the samples into
the leaf boxes and all sorts of
questions that we've all had and and the
whole team at LGC have been amazing
uh and then the funding has come through
mainly innovate UK but also other UK
government sources and
um there was some funding to the um
Nepalese and Pakistan Partners from
their governments as well that has added
to the whole uh achievement
so I shall stop there thank you
I don't know whether you can see me but
it doesn't really matter can you can
everybody hear me okay
yeah perfect okay I'm here so thank you
so much Catherine for an amazing
presentation which was incredibly
informative so what we're going to do
now we're going to go to the live q a
session
um of the webinar if you have any
questions that you'd like to ask please
do so now
um all you need to do is type your
question in ask a question box and
submit and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for oh and
they're coming in already so uh let's
let's go with the first question so
um
so I've got a question about
um what was what source did you take
from Nepal for the aromatic rice so
do you know okay
um so that was actually Pusa Basmati one
um so it was a a line of piece of
Basmati one that was being grown in
Nepal and that was
um
it was crossed
um and used for selection and that
ultimately ended up with the production
with the development of Sonora saganda
which was then the first aromatic modern
aromatic rice that was
um available in Nepal
um the breeding details are in the
papers by professor John Whitcomb and um
the colleagues in Nepal if you want to
have a look at them
um oh what's his name
um I can't remember the name of the guy
that'll come back to me
perfect Krishna Krishna Joshi he now
works for Erie
so that thank you very much Catherine
and I'm sure the everybody's going to be
looking for these super aromatic
varieties now
um so I've got another question that um
is saying that this is a stunning list
of achievements so that's great
um but um so how how long since the
beginning of the project how how long
has it been going on foreign total oh
gosh Dusty how long was it since we had
that first conversation when I said to
you can we convert SSRS into Casp and
you were saying oh well it's not that
simple
which was boots which was great
um so that would have been gone
I think it was 2013 wasn't it it was
very early on
yeah I was going to say I think we wrote
the first
um project proposal in 2014 and we got
it funded in around 2015 it might have
been 2014.
um and then so we had a um one and a
half years of feasibility project and
then I think 2017 we started the
industrial project and that ran through
to the very start of 2021 we hoped we
were going to have six months more
funding unfortunately
um due to various political reasons we
didn't but yeah it we managed to achieve
all of this this is why the database has
been a bit delayed because that end of
the the um funding
um slowed things down but we're still
working on it essentially so yeah so I
mean
but considering you know I mean yes six
seven years but the amount of work that
we was that was done and the
achievements and you know getting even
getting the lines into an advanced state
is is is absolutely amazing
so okay uh let's go on to the next
question
um do the partners in the project think
that the application of cast markers for
micro assisted selection made a
difference to them oh
um definitely definitely I think well
first of all APL weren't using micro
assisted selection before this project
so having access to Casp was a Lifeline
for them for using micro assisted
selection I think all of the others
um
certainly
um
narc and nibji have used them in Market
assisted breeding I don't think school
asked have actually used them for
selection they've mainly used them for
diversity analysis and mapping
but yes they've all felt this has been
made a huge difference to their breeding
programs it's only and it's great the
fact that you know if they've not been
able to apply markers previously you
know the the setup of the all-inclusive
enabled them to do that
absolutely yes
um right
um
the markers that were developed for the
community in rice breathing community in
Nepal Pakistan and India but do you
think these relev these markers are
going to be relevant to other breeders
in other areas of the world
so yes for Rice
um obviously
um this is a panel of markers
specifically for a rise of sativa
um so wherever arises to tiver breeding
is of Interest then there will be
markers here that will that will be
relevant and useful for you I think I um
I made a bit of a mistake when I said it
was one in nine I meant
um
uh nine out of ten or eight out of ten
markers from this set should work in
most possible crosses I'm not quite sure
I was a little bit um in the flow and
didn't um didn't get that right I think
so yeah it's um
basically order at least 10 and you'll
get at least more than half of them
should should amplify should give you a
genotype and hopefully they will give
you useful polymorphisms between the
lines you're interested in whatever
right wherever you're working in the
world on rice if you're working on Rice
wild relatives
excess rate will be lower these have
been designed specifically within a rise
as the Tiger but taking into account a
huge amount of variation within that
species
but that means the density of markers
that were identified should you I mean
they they could be possibilities and of
course you know using the searchable
database that will make it even more
feasible I presume absolutely okay oh
okay with the questions are coming in
um what was the rationale for select the
full selection of markers sets for
targeted sequencing and as a follow-up
how many cast markers do you think would
be needed for routine quality checking
on varieties and hybrids that's a big
question
yeah
um
yeah yeah go on sorry what was the
rationale for the selection of Marcus
Marcus said
for targeted sequencing okay
um
okay so the targeted sequencing so
that's the seek snip
um so basically we designed that uh
rationale was to design Casp in this
project and so the seek snip were kind
of a byproduct of the cast designs so
the rationale for Cass was
um
um a design that was going to work for
Casp so
um to run a cap you need to have a
either a snip or an indel that is
um unique that
um doesn't have any extra variation
um or more complex variation
um so it needs to be one that
um
yeah it's going to work as a Casp but we
also
um then when we when we ran the
um seek snip we chose markers that we
hadn't actually run as Casp previously
um to then up the num the amount of
coverage of the genome within the
available budget the beauty of seek snip
is that you can run a lot more markers
than you can running Casp and actually
if if we're doing the project now now
that seek snip is available I would
start off with running seek snip that
are designed as Casp and then use those
to inform the set of most useful cast to
to Zone in on as it were
um because you can run a lot more seek
Snips
um for this for the budget that you can
do for Casp so yeah it's kind of back to
front we we chose the seek snip that we
hadn't run as Casp but you you could
start off using just seeksnip and then
home in on the ones that you want for
Casp if you've got the budget to do it
that way around
um I mean in actual fact you know you
can you know there's the seat snip is
kind of enabling verification you know
within the genome and then you can as
you move down the breeding program you
could convert them to cast to have a
lower density set of markers yes yes
absolutely so what was the follow on uh
the follow-up was
um
how many cast markers do you think you
would need for routine uh quality uh
checking uh yeah and hybrids okay so
that's so basically when we did the seek
snip we were targeting markers that
would be useful for purification so we
were looking
um within very closely related lines and
um ultimately wanted to identify the
ones that that would be polymorphic but
when we once we got that down to that we
we had
um it was in the 30s the number of of
Casp that we actually needed
um cost wise I think the smallest number
that it's worthwhile running is either
24 or 48 I think
um obviously Dusty you you know the um
the pricing structures and people need
to ask what what the um what those are
and how many but I think um I think 24
is the smallest number of Casp you can
you can order
um you know if you want to run less than
that it's it's worth trying to find some
extra ones just to to fill up your your
set
to make it cost efficient yes yeah yeah
for sure
but you can I mean you can just get away
with a small number depending on what
you're actually interested in doing
whether it's microcity's selection of a
particular Locus for example I mean if
you just want to you can just run the
fragrance marker it's just one but it'll
tell you whether you've got varieties
with that allele or the wrong allele
um but yeah it's not cost effective to
just run one Casp no no definitely well
I mean the effort it takes to produce
all the DNA then the obvious there's
there's it's better to choose a few more
um
so this is we've only got a minute left
so this is a question from me do you
think the re-sequencing uh the data that
was used part of the resequencing
develop haplotype Maps
for implementation
you could
um we've not used used it for appetite
Maps um but the data are all there the
sequences that we did in this project
um are all on available oh the first
nine are all available in databases so
you can actually go and find that
original sequence data and use that for
um that analysis type mapping yeah it's
all out there I think the um
there's two extra that we need to load
up
um from the
um last lot of sequencing that was done
um for the newer designs but that is
it's all in the public domain or will
all be in the public domain and all the
other sequences were in the 3K Vice
Genome Project
um and there's there's more and more ice
genomes becoming available so yeah if
you wanted to do that you can do that
but we've not done it no well I mean but
that's you know that's an idea for
people on how they can use this the data
that's been generated within this so
so I think that's all we've got time for
so thank you so much Catherine very so
much fun to do with this to do this with
you again
um and any final comments for our
audience
do you have any any cop any final
comments for the audience oh sorry I was
just looking to see if there were any
more questions from the audience but
yeah we haven't got time for that um I I
think we've covered everything it's just
um yeah get in touch with LGC if you
want to know any more
thanks
all right thank you again
um
um for your time the time you've taken
out to be part of this and of course
you're incredibly important research
that's going to change people's lives so
I would also like to thank lab Roots
um for their help with setting up the
webinar couldn't have done it without
them and of course LGC for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before I go obviously I want to thank
everybody who's attended and joined us
today and and thanks for the really good
questions
um and if they're if we haven't answered
any questions then we will get in
contact with you
um and get those questions answered for
you